hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so in this video what we're
going to talk about is how to factor by
splitting the middle term so what you'll
notice in these three examples that
we're going to go through is that that
leading coefficient of this trinomial is
not 1 and so what we can do is a couple
different things one thing is teachers
often teach the the trial and error
method the guess and check method but
the method we're going to be doing here
is a little bit more direct and it's a
little bit more process-oriented so a
lot of times students find this to be a
lot easier so let's get into some
examples and I'll show you what I mean
so this first example what you want to
do is you want to take the leading
coefficient times the constant so you
say to yourself what two numbers
multiply to four so I'll just make a
little chart here so what two numbers
multiply to four but at the same time
those same two numbers have to add to
the middle coefficient five ok sorry
with me so far so what do you think
those two numbers are then multiply to
four but add to five okay so if you said
four and one you're absolutely right
because four plus one is five four times
one is four and then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna split this middle term
okay so instead of 5x we're going to
split it up into four acts a plus 1x now
where did I get the four x + 1 X from
that's from these two numbers here then
you just bring down the 2 ok that last
term and you bring down the 2 x squared
that's the first term ok so now what you
notice is we have four terms when you
have four terms like this what you can
do is you can try and do the factoring
by grouping method what you do is you
put parentheses around the first two
terms and you put parentheses around the
last two terms then all you have to do
is factor out the greatest common factor
out of each group so I'm going to factor
out 2x here so that's going to leave us
with X plus 2 and I really can't Factor
anything out of here except for a 1 and
that also leaves us with X plus 2 so see
how we have an X plus 2 in common in
this group as well as this group so what
you can do is you can factor out X plus
2 again as if it was a greatest common
factor okay and what you're left with is
2x plus 1 and if
want to check your answer all you have
to do is go ahead and distribute the X
distribute the to simplify and you're
gonna get back the original polynomial
that we started with so let's go on to
the next example before I do that if
you're preparing for the AC T I'm gonna
have a link to the video course that I
created for that to help students you
know boost their score with a math
portion of the AC T so if you're
interested in that check that out well
let's get into this next example here so
what we're going to do is same idea we
notice that this is a trinomial and the
leading coefficient is 3 ok so we're
going to do is we're going to take 3
times 16 and ask ourselves what two
numbers multiply to 48 you get a product
of 3 and 16 but they have to add to the
middle coefficient negative 26 so can
you think of what those two numbers are
this is the hardest part of the problem
if you can get past this part the rest
is just going to be process-oriented
it's going to be more direct and you'll
get right to your factored solution but
you can see here this is going to be 24
and 2 and these are going to both be
negative because a negative times a
negative is a positive and a negative 24
plus a negative 2 is a negative 26 once
you get those two numbers
you're almost there you just split that
middle term into negative 24x and
negative 2x bring down the 16 and bring
down the 3x squared and then all you
have to do is do the factoring by
grouping now I'm going to show you a
little technique here you see this minus
sign I'm just gonna make this as adding
the opposite so that when I go to group
the last two terms and group the first
two terms I just have a plus sign in
between those two groups so now we're
just going to factor out the GCF which
is 3x and we're going to be left with X
minus 8 here we're going to factor out a
negative 2 and we're going to be left
with X minus 8 so you can see there's an
X minus 8 in both these groups we're
going to factor out that X minus 8 and
when we do that we're left with 3x minus
2 so again this part here can sometimes
be little bit confusing but if you think
of taking this X minus 8 as a group and
distributing it to the 3x you're going
to get back this group if you take this
whole X minus 8 and distribute to the
negative
you're gonna get back that whole group
and if you foil this out you'll see that
you're gonna get back to the original so
one last example for for good measure
we're just gonna take the ten times
negative six and ask ourselves what two
numbers multiply to negative 60 but at
the same time they have to add to the
middle coefficient 11 and what do you
think those two numbers would be well it
looks like one has to be positive one
has to be negative so we're gonna make
this 15 and negative four okay because
15 plus negative 4 is 11 15 times
negative 4 is negative 60 and we got it
all we have to do is split that middle
term 15 X and negative 4 X bring down
the 6 and bring down the 10 x squared
I'm going to change a subtraction sign
to adding the opposite and then I'm
going to group the first two terms and
I'm going to group the last two terms
and now we're gonna factor out the
greatest common factor out of both
groups so we're gonna factor out a 5 X
so that leaves us with 2x plus 3 we're
going to factor out a negative 2 that
leaves us with 2x plus 3 and now you can
see the 2x plus 3 is in common we can
factor that 2x plus 3 out and we're left
with 5x minus 2 now the nice thing about
factoring is you can go ahead and
multiply this out and make sure you get
back to the original that way you know
you've factored it correctly so I hope
you're enjoying the video subscribe to
the channel check out some of my past
videos I have a video that's all about
factoring you can check that out and
I'll see you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon